howdy quick question does dialogflow cx
integrate with telephone providers
yes it does can i learn more about the
ivr features
sure then stay tuned to learn more
[Music]
for a full voice experience your
dialogue slow cx agent can be integrated
with various conversation platforms
such as avaya genesis mitel 5.9
vonage and more these providers offer a
user interface for callers
and pass their questions through
dialogflow's api
it's important to note that every
platform's integration handles
interactions in their own unique way
so depending on the telephony provider
you use you will need to review
their specific documentation so let's
take a tour
when we dive into dialogue slow cx's
console on the left side
we click the manage tab and scroll down
to the section called
integrations under the one-click
telephony header
you will find partner built-in telephony
integrations that were created by google
partners
in collaboration with google the
following partners are listed as of the
making of this video
which are avaya and audio codes there
are also
independent integrations that are not
built in that are created by
organizations and individuals they are
built
using the dialogflow api and as a
friendly heads up
when you need support for any telephony
integration
the partners are the folks that will
assist you
with that being said the overall process
will be to build your google cloud
project
enable the dialog flow api within your
project
and then create a dialogflow cx agent
since most agent conversations are built
within
many flows and pages in mind you will
also typically build a
webhook service to generate a dynamic
response based on your business's logic
you will also most likely need to keep
in mind certain pieces of information
for the integration such as your project
id agent id
and or the api key ivr settings can be
found
at three different levels in dialog flow
at the agent level flow level and page
level
for starters you must first enable the
agent level settings
and select the speech and idr tab
then under the advanced settings toggle
the enable
advanced settings on
there are three features to note the
first is called
end of speech sensitivity which helps
determine
how sensitive the speech end pointing
should be when a caller finishes
speaking
and it uses google cloud speech
next is barge in which allows the
speaker to
interrupt the agent this is helpful so
that the caller doesn't have to wait to
hear the full response
from the agent in order to speak or
another way of looking at it
is if you disable the bargin setting the
agent would only begin to listen to a
caller speech until
it has completely finished playing its
response
and last is the google cloud storage uri
which enables you to reference a google
cloud storage path
back in order to access pre-recorded
audio
after enabling ivr settings at the agent
level
you can also customize ivr settings
further on a per flow level
you can do this by hovering over a flows
name click the dots icon
and choose flow settings then you toggle
enable advanced speech settings
by enabling ivr features at the flow
level they override the agent level ivr
settings it was defaulting to
this is extremely useful if you want to
have different ivr settings in a
multi-flow
agent the third level of ivr settings
resides
on each page you can access these by
hovering over a page
clicking the dots then selecting page
settings
and same as a flow a pages ivr settings
will default to the agent settings
or flow settings unless you specifically
select
customize at the page level now you may
be thinking
when might i want to use the page and
flow level settings
this depends on your use case for
example let's say
as a user dictates and pauses in between
numbers such as
my account number is two three
four five six seven eight
nine the user benefits from extending
the timeout so you may want to make sure
that the timeout setting isn't too short
or the user will be cut off which is
very rude in conversations furthermore
if i stayed silent because i didn't know
my account number
and i was looking for it then tweaking
the
no speech timeout setting will allow the
agent to help me by further prompting me
on where to get that account number and
there you have it
a quick walkthrough of ivr features and
settings
in dialogflow cx i left some helpful
links in this video's description if you
would like to learn more or if you
missed any of our previous videos on
dialogflow cx
i hope to see you in the next episode of
deconstructing chat bots
if you like this video and would like to
see more of this type of content
it helps to like and subscribe to our
channel
cheers and thank you for watching